عندنا موعد
لعبه وتجربه اعددنا بعض المقاطع الموسيقيه
لكل منها لون مختلف لكنها اثبتت نجاح في
تعزيز الانتاجيه عندك كثير من الموظفين
اثناء العمل المطلوب ان زملائنا يقيمون ما
اذا كان من المحتمل ان نختار موسيقى تحفز
معدل انتاجيتهم ام لا
بدنا منهم او كانت محفزه ترفعوا اصبعكم
هيك او العكس
سمعونا
[موسيقى]
ها فوق ولا تحت
يلا اللي بعدها
للعمل احنا قاعدين
[موسيقى]
خبر سياسي
اختلفوا
شكله شكله ولاء قالت لا علاء قال لا شدان
قالت يمكن انا شايفه يمكن اول اول قط
مقطوعه موسيقيه هي ازبطشي
ريح
ولا لا على لا
اتفقوا على انه لا مع انه بحر اعتقد
ما هو على حسب هذا الموضوع لشو يا عادل
لانه يعني
ولاء وشهدان شكرا جزيلا انكم مفصولين ان
شاء الله
من الملاحظ بانه بالفعل يعني كل شخص عنده
ذوق مختلف في الموضوع لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات